okay i'm going to change the subject
here i want to talk about uh tesla
fanboys it's just hard switch dude
i have to because i just came came upon
this image
yeah upon this image that you sent
this one right here oh this yeah this
tweet
man if you're listening on audio all
right basically
it's a dude doing a gender reveal on
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is like
his 10 acre vineyard
or some [ __ ] it looks like a green
screen
yeah i don't even know if it's real but
it's him and his lady and they're
holding up the uh
sonogram is that what it's called yeah
probably
no holding up they're holding up like
the photo booth reel of their [ __ ]
embryo
and um they're they're posted up on
their
model 3 and next to it is a baby blue
miniature uh what is that
model class model s yeah and that's
their gender reveal
and then he he posted it and then he
replied to his own tweet and said at
elon musk sponsor my unborn child
my man that is that like
is that like some code for like you know
you sponsor my unborn child like the
tesla cult [ __ ] for like [ __ ] my wife
yeah maybe maybe it's code for something
elon i'd love it if you sponsored my
unborn child
yes i could sponsor you how do you like
tesla that much
it's a [ __ ] i mean it's like really a
lifestyle for these people it's like
they [ __ ] love tesla they love buying
tesla stock
they love talking about tesla it's like
teslas are cool but like it's just a
[ __ ] car
and you know what you know what i can
hear already
what i did you [ __ ] like the fast and
furious and all
like you're really into cars it's the
same thing it's not
it's not the same thing it's not really
yeah it's not really nothing because if
you're like a little tuner head or
a gear head or or you know petrol ed
typically you get so into the into your
car because you work on it you build it
you save your money you buy parts for it
you make it faster it like becomes a
part of you
because you put energy into it
these shits came out like and they're
just to me
it's like loving a roomba and creating a
a community around a roomba it's just
yeah oh my god it's revolutionizing
cleaning and
you know just the whole home care space
it's like how do you give a [ __ ]
that much yeah yeah it's like
at least at least i guess in other car
um spaces it's like there there's a lot
of variety
like people get into the differences
between cars and the ones faster and
one's not and the mods you can do
every tesla is the same is that everyone
is just collectively waiting for the
next software update for them to be
different
right and i i admit the software updates
are [ __ ] cool like
kelsey's dad was just showing me his his
one they just did an update where you
can now play music
out like on external speakers in your
car
nice so when you like play fart sounds
and you make your like honk sound
different yeah
it's [ __ ] wonky slime like stuff like
that i like teslas for like zany
little quirky [ __ ] like that that make
them different from other boring cars
but that's it that's as far as it goes
no that's definitely a reason like start
a podcast and
buy three of them and tesla t-shirts and
hats and
you know fingerless gloves yeah tesla
underwear tesla socks
tesla tequila gotta you know smash that
tesla flamethrower
and lit uh tesla shoes tesla condoms
yes even when i'm [ __ ] dude
even when i'm [ __ ] i know elon's not
too far away you know
elon is gonna [ __ ] put out a vibrator
you just
know yeah he's just so deep in the
battery game yeah
he's gonna well
we figured when you're sitting around at
the charging station
some people find that they fall down the
back seats and
to enjoy each other's company so
we came up with a sort of self-pleasure
mechanism
in the car so we've partnered with
sybian we've actually
put the nub in the trunk so you follow
down all the seats your
wife can ride she can literally [ __ ] the
car
or you can yeah wow
that's wonderful have you ever had elk
meat
[Laughter]
why does i have a live i actually cut
open an elk
army hammer thanks for joining me
army hammer good to see you buddy good
to see you yeah you know man
crazy world crazy world right now man
what do you think about everything
that's going on right now
well i'm just excited to be here because
i don't know anyone else that shares
such a passion for
me to like uh like oh like you do like
yeah and i know yeah you appreciate it
i've seen those
what you post on instagram the the few
of the pig head
yeah i've seen that that's yeah that's
i'm more of an elk man myself you ever
had elk meat
oh yeah yeah oh man you throw it on the
grill and get a little salt and pepper
on there get inside
i am rare it's spring that's how i what
you're right you're an elk brain an elk
brain
no that's some sort of thick
bro speaking of [ __ ] we should address
what the hell you were saying at the top
of the episode
your [ __ ] is mine ah i know
it's a little late now but is that that
could be not that's a that's a solid
bone zone one i feel like the cat's
gonna go crazy on that one okay oh yeah
that's fine we're gonna tell that one on
the bottom
what we should do though real quick
since we got short time and we don't
want to talk about it forever is
that lewis hamilton post that [ __ ]
baby filter post he put up
oh my god i wrote that on screen okay
yeah
with the bucket hat dude
and the [ __ ] boy necklaces like he's got
three necklaces on
bro he put this on his story and he
cropped it
and he put it on his he he put it as a
static post
yeah with the same the caption is the
same text and then he tweeted
it my [ __ ] man he obviously thought
he was
he looked like fly as hell bro the baby
filter
kills me what is that filter and this
this angle from up here with the hand in
his back
just just relaxing just being cat
it's it's cute and it's like cute like
he looks like
alpha but he also looks like maybe he's
got like a softer side you know
like he's just just relaxing says
thank you all for the birthday wishes i
hope i hope and pray
wherever you are you are staying
positive despite what's happening around
us
my birthday wish is peace and love to
all of you out there
no more pandemic and equality for all of
us
wait wait wait my birthday wishes peace
and love to all of you out there
no more no more pandemic and equality
i don't want any
[Laughter]
you need a period in there dude i want
to put a stop to a quality quality
and the pandemic really dude you want
equality
okay give up give up 300 million dollars
to us please to us you want a quality
give us
300 million dollars man i want that
bucket hat dude
i'm telling you because i believe in
manifestation and if we put it into the
universe and we come together i believe
we can get there
it's not really his voice at all sending
you all love and positivity
damn oh louis dude he's so hot
oh i'm praying as well bro
this [ __ ] dude my birthday wish is peace
like
that is such some cult leader [ __ ] you
know what i mean
that's like a guy in like [ __ ] uh
like laurel canyon with like a group of
15
you know pale women who take
psychedelics like obsessed with them you
know that's some [ __ ] he says
to them well this is this is the best
part too okay so oh yeah birthday wish
is equality right and his birthday wish
is peace
oh he wants he thought in his head when
they said blow the candles
he thought and and make a wish he
thought peace and then you blow the
candles
let's also talk about his [ __ ]
rumored requirements for him to race
another [ __ ] year
four year 200 million dollar salary
okay 50 mil a year doesn't end there
no no he wants 10 percent of mercedes
winnings which is a [ __ ] ton of money
[ __ ] ton of money
let me google that real quick how much
did f1 mercedes win
2020 um constructor's title
how much money does the winning team get
a hundred million
so he just wants another just another 10
million on top just a little
sprinkle that on he also wants the
limited production amg one car which to
me sounds like you know that's like a
driver's version of their own shoe he
wants his own shoe
okay um and then this is the best a role
that goes beyond being a driver and more
than a mere testimonial
what even is that in the context of a
formula one card
what do you want to be like what is that
what else is there
i mean cody was saying he wants to be
the only music artist that can mention
amg
and music anymore like they every
[ __ ] rapper gets a cease and desist
and only lewis can talk about mercedes
cars unless he gets a little percentage
yeah yeah yes he has to get a little
royalty he's got to be cut in you want
to talk about mercedes like that
i don't see i don't see it's weird i
don't see peace on here at all
maybe they cropped it was there a fifth
bullet point that said yes just peace
and and also equality as well equality
as well
now you can want those things in 200
million you can want both
yeah you could want a quality and also
200 million dollars yeah why not
why not it's fair yeah bro i just i
can't like
the great part is is ever since i
started bringing this [ __ ] on the
podcast
the small amount of f1 fans we have
they're always like sending me his
stories and they go
man this has completely changed the way
i look at this dude
the amount of shirtless running story
posts that guy has
yeah like he's got more than todd smith
in a in a month
like shout out todd todd you do your
thing you run
it's a genuine thing you're like i'm out
here on a run but louis i'm surprised
that guy
doesn't have that [ __ ] phone on like
a
like some kind of like gopro rig from
his waist yeah yeah
he can run too armed yeah
pull his hair back
it's [ __ ] hot up here yeah in monaco
where i don't pay taxes on my
hundreds of millions of earnings [ __ ] i
want world peace
i've just been thinking about how badly
i want world peace
that's nice up here in monaco i wish all
of you could see this
i wish i wish i wish everyone in the
world lived in monaco and we were so
they could
see them they could see the world like i
do
they can see the peace brewing on the
other side of the sun
and he gets a [ __ ] literally a
thousand dms every time oh my god lewis
oh my god fly me to monaco
i mean a monika oh my god ew
you know he's reading those like oh
[ __ ] disgusting
never you never [ __ ]
he's just so judgmental look at this
[ __ ]
swamp donkey that just dm'd me
he like immediately look at him
absolute monster
ew i think she has three eyes look at
her
look at her look at this [ __ ] she's
wearing glosses
[ __ ] disgusting this [ __ ] thinks i'd
fly her to monaco bro i wouldn't fly her
[ __ ] home
[Laughter]
it's just [ __ ] rude as [ __ ]
just super shitty
oh [ __ ] she's a two [ __ ] puked in my
mouth
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] orc that just
oh [ __ ] oh look at this fantastic four
villain right here look at this [ __ ]
oh my god you need the avengers to work
on her jesus christ look at that
wow
you